I learned six million dollar lessons at
my first job working hot summers as an
18 year old in a warehouse at a fifth
generation fur coat dealer and this
business made it through two world wars
multiple recessions and these lessons I
have taken with me for Life the first
lesson he ever taught me was how to deal
with angry customers
this lady comes in and she is piss angry
he's like where's Johnny he sold me this
coat and this button came off this is so
ridiculous I spent so much money on this
coach she's just making a scene I didn't
go in the retail store that much because
like I looked like an 18 year old and I
wasn't going to be selling any 25 000
codes John the owner of the store I'm on
the other side of the door so she can't
see me and he's walking towards me to
turn out to go deal with her as he's
walking towards me I see him roll his
eyes and then as he turns a corner he
goes right into character Mrs Johnson
that is ridiculous I cannot believe that
you had a coat that had a button that
was missing Who Sold you that coat I
need to find them right now we'll get
rid of them did anyone see you with the
coat without the button we're going to
get to the bottom of this right now all
of a sudden her whole tone changes she
started backpedaling and she's like I
mean it you know it wasn't that big of a
deal like it was it was just a button it
probably no we need to get to the bottom
of this this is not acceptable and she
all of a sudden became calmness to me
she's like you know what I I just I just
want it to be fixed if you could fix the
coat and he's he grabbed it from he's
like we're gonna handle this right now
he goes to the back they fix the thing
in five minutes he hands it back to her
and she's like oh John you're always the
best thank you so much for dealing with
this I'm sorry I was a little bit over
the top I just you know I've spent so
much in the jacket and he's like as you
should be she walked out the door he
turned him in he was like
and he said there could only be one
person in the angry boat so whenever
someone comes in the angry bug what most
people try and do is they try and
downplay them and so they say well it's
not that big of a deal and what happens
is the person doesn't feel validated the
person who's upset then increases how
angry they are because they want the
person to validate why they're angry and
so what happens they just keep getting
angry and this person keeps trying to
make them less angry and then just
creates more and more of a discrepancy
between the two people now the flip side
is she got in the angry boat and so she
had to get out of the angry boat and so
whenever you're dealing with an upset
customer you need to validate their
anger and in a real way if something was
messed up and you have very high stands
for your business the moment you say
it's not a big deal it means you're not
actually taking responsibility even if
their complaint is ridiculous it still
is your responsibility and so you have
to take ownership of it because the
alternative is you don't and you never
get better the second lesson he taught
me was about creating a new product they
realized that in the summer they never
had any demand because people aren't
trying to buy fur coats in the summer
and they're like huh what can we sell to
people during the summer and so it came
up with a genius idea we'll store and
condition the coats for them as they
sold every single customer code they
said hey every year make sure during the
summer when you're not using the code
you bring it back here we can repair any
damages we can sew things up we can
condition the fur and we can make it
last two three five times longer so you
can pass it on to the next of kin and
then he would give this a little analogy
he's like right if you're going to buy a
50 000 car you'd pay a hundred bucks a
month for insurance it's the same thing
here Sue created this analogy that
compared for codes which people didn't
understand as well to a car which was
something they did and so what happened
is overnight he created what I would
consider an insurance product Insurance
products don't actually have to be
Insurance you can charge people for the
safety that whatever they just bought
will continue to provide value for a
longer period of time and the cost to
deliver on this was so low because we
had one 18 year old two air conditioning
three storage facility and the upsell
was lesson three was getting people to
say yes by saying no when I first
learned no base selling I actually
learned it from this job when I was
saying team storage is the first core
thing which is I just hang your code up
and I keep it air conditioned and the
upsell is I'll also brush it and I'll
fix it and I'll do these other things
and so when they would call up customers
and they'd say hey you know turn in your
code for the summer what they did was
say hey we're going to store and
condition the coat you don't want
anything else do you and they would say
no no I don't want anything else and so
implied in that they got them to say yes
to storage and yes to conditioning the
code it's pretty slick people want to
just get the default option we're so
trained to say no to any kind of upsells
that if you get someone to say no but in
so doing get them to say yes you
actually click into their subconscious
automated response most times when they
say no to salesmen they save money you
flip the script and you align it so that
them saying no actually gets them to say
yes for you end of the purchase so
Lesson Four when they wanted to get
people to actually take them up on the
upsell that they had they gave them a
little piece of bait and it was what I
call sawdust and so sawdust is anything
in a business that is created in excess
that you normally throw out so a lot of
famous things were actually made out of
sawdust Ikea pieces of furniture they
just glued together all the sawdust from
Lumber Mills whey protein used to get
scraped off the bottom of dairy centers
because it was waste product and now is
is one of the most expensive products
sold from dairy what he did was he took
the scraps from all the coats that they
would make in the back they made tiny
little things that were made of fur so
think like little purses little ear
muffs and so he said anybody who would
turn in their coat would get this as a
bonus they gave away something that cost
them nothing that people still perceive
value as bait to get people to come in
and actually take the upsell what's even
more when people did come to turn the
thing in they would actually say well
you want to store that too right and
they would say yes and then they would
charge them for that even though they
got the product for free the storage
didn't come free and if people were
listening to this if you're listening to
this and you're a consumer you have to
get around the like someone selling me
something makes them evil capitalism is
the only system where both people say
thank you after an exchange it means
both parties are better and if someone
threatens you that's different that's
not that's just a form of robbery but if
I say would you like this thing and the
other person says yes and they give me
money and I give them the thing no harm
was done if someone didn't want to store
the earmuffs then they didn't have to
and they just got it for free which is a
benefit and for the business just the
cost of doing business is to get the
person in the door how he was able to
double the amount of coats people would
buy the first who said no dealers
everyone who's a consumer thinks oh
these must be great deals that's why
dealers aren't allowed once they got in
there was a sign on the door that said
limit two quotes per customer they're
like oh there's a limit I have to use up
the scarce resource on top of that they
would have multiple strike Downs on the
price it said final price all sales are
final and he purposely let people in on
a single file line and a fixed amount of
people in the store at the same time it
created this huge perception of demand
and you feel like you got to go get
yours by creating this continuity
product where people would come every
year to get their fur coat insured and
fixed you become the dealer for life and
so what happens is instead of them Price
shopping you were going all over town
what they'll do instead is they go to
you first instead of being that one
salesman who sells one car one time you
become the car salesman for the rest of
your life because of what you do between
the sales so in your business if you
have a one-time product especially
that's a little bit bigger in purchase
having little things that you can do
even if you didn't make money on them
and then you know that on average you
get customers to buy two more products
from you it more than makes up for the
effort and cost of time that you put
into it and this leads me to my final
lesson this fur coat dealer was able to
withstand all of the pita pressures and
all of the you know people being upset
about animals even though they wear
leather and they eat meat every day he
was able to weather that for five
generations because he never stopped
doing the boring work what they do has
not changed fundamentally in years all
they did was get better and better and
better at it one of the things that I
found through all the portfolio
companies that we work with where you
own access is not going to portfolio
there's 200 million dollars a year the
difference between small business owners
and the big business owners is that the
big business owners do the same thing
for a very long period of time they do
all the things that right now you
probably know you should be doing but
aren't in your business they just do
those they just do all the basics every
time every day and if you're like man
but it's going to take me time to set up
a Blog it's taking me time to do email
follow-up consistently it's gonna take
me time to create content it's going to
take me time to build a sales team yeah
there's all the things that you probably
know you should do and they take time
which is why building a business that's
big takes big time but it also creates
even bigger outcomes